depuis de trop nombreuses heures nos
policiers nos gendarmes et nos
sapeurs-pompiers sont mobilisés partout
en France nous avons néanmoins franchi
un nouveau cap dans la violence mais le
problème c'est que les lois et la
culture du nos dirigeants de son plus
adaptés à la situation des
rassemblements un peu partout dans les
Yvelines et lui est habitant était
nombreux à avoir répondu à l'appel de
l'association des maires de France à se
réunir ce lundi à midi
trois jours après la taxe subie par la
famille du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans
le Val-de-Marne et dans le contexte de
tension et d'émeutes qui touchent le
territoire les mers ont répondu à
l'appel à se rassembler ce rassemblement
c'est décidé hier il était tout à fait
normal que j'y participe à la fois parce
qu'il t'arrivait à notre collègue mère
de L'Haÿ-les-Roses qui est absolument
insupportable et on le ressent tous dans
notre cher mais aussi pour en profiter
pour passer un nouvel appel au calme à
mon repas aussi se rassemblement était
indispensable pour le maire de la ville
il faut appeler à l'ordre républicain au
calme et l'objectif maintenant c'est
d'apporter des solutions nous en
développant maintenant depuis nous des
années sur notre territoire
donc voilà l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'était surtout de rappeler
que nous soutenions nos forces de
l'ordre et l'ensemble des élus de la
France une soixantaine deux personnes
étaient également réunies à Élancourt
pour suivre le discours du maire et
réaffirmer leur soutien aux élus nos
administrés
ont envie de faire remonter à leurs élus
ce qu'ils vivent ce que ça les a quand
même inquiété et puis montrer bien sûr
que les les mers sont sont là et que ils
n'ont pas l'intention de céder à ce
genre de Chantal qui est contre
l'intérêt général un sentiment que
partage les habitants des communes qui
tenaient à répondre présent à l'appel
comme semble tout à fait
de nos élus étant donné que c'est
maintenant on voit que c'est le surtout
le tissu finalement
républicain qui a attaqué donc moi je
pense que on est la majorité silencieuse
on nous entend jamais d'habitude là
c'est l'occasion de montrer qu'on est
quand même là faut il faut que les deux
camps arrivent à trouver les solutions
qui vont dans l'intérêt du pays parce
que on est appelé à vivre ensemble et à
cette jeunesse ce serait bien ça serait
dommage que elle soit comme ça paumée
perdu tout ça c'est une énergie qu'il
faut exploiter bien encadrer et les
écouter en soutien auxédils Emmanuel
Macron recevra 220 mères victimes
d'exaction à l'Elysée ce mardi